I don't support immigrants coming from
countries whose major religion is
designed to destroy me there's this
constant fear in America that this is a
threat to our national security but I've
seen these immigrants build this because
this is home
[Music]
you
my name is Ken Unger I'm a
transformational speaker writer and
filmmaker I'm Jacob
I have a textile business my work life
is very intense but we'll put on music
and start dancing the biggest thing that
shaped me was that I was healed of an
incurable disease I was addicted to
prescription drugs absolutely miserable
couldn't think of a reasonable limit
instead I looked at the Bible and it was
all making sense was instantly delivered
from the disease so that was the major
turning point since then I just wanted
to help people so that's my mission all
my books all my movies that I make are
all about how to heal and become better
people and make the world a better place
I was born in Tehran Iran during the
Islamic Revolution an attack happened
and my parents were like enough is
enough that night we were smuggled out
of Iran I remember that was probably one
of the most beautiful nights of my life
everyone's happy because they like made
it out safely yeah so a lot happened but
I grew up in Los Angeles I think America
is set up to take the best we always
have tried to do that we don't accept
people to come your world each off of us
we don't accept people who come here
want to destroy us we don't owe anybody
access to America America is a place
where a bunch of people have come and
they form neighborhoods and they live
together and if you're a part of that
and you're contributing to that that
makes you American we have a sign on our
door that says this business is owned
and operated by immigrants we're lucky
to have so many people from so many
parts of the world here
and I'm proud to be a part of that I
believe what Trump's trying to
accomplish I believe the vast majority
of Americans want him to accomplish keep
us safe Trump has the courage because
he's not bought and paid for
he loves the country and he wants to
change the things that have really sold
all of us down the river
and he's doing a pretty good job
I remember coming here as a kid I was
asked what my race was I'd never thought
about that white identity is a big part
of American history
but something happened a few years ago
that was very significant white people
became the minority I think that has
created this fear in America
the problem is jihadism they want to
kill us and they want to take over and
immigration is part of the strategy that
has nothing to do with America and could
eventually unravel our society and we
should never tolerate that here
extremism is wrong there is a huge issue
with radical Islam but I think that's an
effect of our policies in the Middle
East for so many years now if we really
want to eradicate radicalization we need
to really look at the kind of
governments we support because as long
as we're creating suffering that threat
of people coming here to do harm to the
United States is going to be increased
and then you say how did this happen how
did we get here I honestly believe that
Trump may become one of our most
successful presidents in history he's
trying to give us our freedom back and I
think a free and educated America is
gonna do fly I'm very excited about life
I'm healthier than I've ever been you
know I'm a transformational writer I
want to create films and television that
make the world a better place I mean
this is a special place I think we all
take it for granted so many amazing
people that are doing amazing things
these immigrants that are being vilified
now build this they're a part of the
city they made it happen they're the
community that's what makes America
beautiful that's my story
[Music]
you know I got my citizenship six seven
years ago
and it sounds silly but that day I felt
really like an American that I don't
have to worry now when I travel that
created a sense that I think not
belonging but unless American as apple
by now
I think it's still the best place to do
don't America be America I think I'm
very lucky
[Music]
because this is phone
you